Liam Halligan nice to see welcome to
tickling me thank you hello and welcome
to trigonometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
constant in Kissin and this is the show
for you if you were sick of people
arguing on the internet about subjects
they know nothing about at trigonometry
we don't pretend to be experts we ask
the experts
we're here the world-famous angel comedy
club and our amazing expert guest guest
this week is a journalist economist
broadcaster and the author of clean
brexit lim Halligan nice to say welcome
to chicken
[Music]
[Applause]
Liam so before we get started one other
thing we always likes like to ask our
guests is just tell us a little bit
about your background how is it that you
are who you are today okay so I'm was
born into a working-class family in
London I was the first person in my
family to go to university I'm from a
Irish background which wasn't always
easy growing up in the 70s I and I'm an
economist by training I was an academic
for a while then I became a newspaper
columnist so I've written a column in
The Daily Telegraph for about almost 20
years now a weekly column and I write
columns elsewhere too I've spent quite a
lot of time in Russia both in the 90s as
a journalist and then more recently I do
a show three times a week on CNN so I've
got a portfolio career I'm not I think a
lot of people in British journalism
don't quite know where to define me and
where to categorize me I I guess that's
the way I like it
and one of the things we'll be
definitely talking a lot about today's
Russia tell us a little bit about your
time because we've talked about this
before yeah so my first went to Russia
in the early 90s as an academic and I
ended up working alongside a lot of
other much more senior economists on the
reform program that was going on it was
obviously for somebody like me
interested in economics and politics it
was like history on speed you know
Francis Fukuyama had just written in
1989 it's the end of history no Frances
sped up and to being Russia during that
period it was it was a very difficult
time for a lot of Russian people it was
under llego guide our who you remember
the prime minister at the time it was a
an area that some people call shock
therapy when the Soviet Union had
collapsed just a few years before prices
went through the roof the planned
economy didn't work anymore you had a
nascent private sector that was trying
to emerge
you had a lot of Russian people were
very very scared about what was going to
happen they went from sort of superpower
to basket case in just a few months but
then again you know you had all that
incredible ingenuity
skill and drive that the rest of the
world knows that Russians have so for me
as a young man it was an incredibly
interesting time it made me into a
journalist I ended up as covering Russia
for The Economist and then I came back
to the UK in the late 90s when I joined
the Financial Times more recently from
2010 until 2013 I lived in Russia but
this time working in financial services
I took a few years out of journalism I
kept writing my columns from about 2008
to 2013
working in an asset management company
and that asset management company
focused on the post-communist world so
Russia the broader CIS Eastern Europe
and that was a great opportunity for me
to really really serious adult research
interest was the post-communist world
and it's mainly a sort of British
commentator these days but I do try and
keep a close eye on that region and
travel there as often as I can
what how do you see Russia's role in the
world at the moment because you read
some papers and it's they've sort of
been portrayed almost as the enemy of
the West to buy into that narrative
well since the Cold War ended we've gone
through kind of peaks and troughs
haven't we yeah I mean you know Vladimir
Putin came in in the late 1990s nobody
knew who he was replace Yeltsin George
Bush jr. said I look into a soul I can
see his eyes there was a sort of real
loving after 9/11 in 2001 folklore has
it the first call that George Bush got
was from Putin saying you guys want to
use our bases in Kazakhstan you want to
access Afghanistan from Russian
territory that's absolutely fine and yet
since then we've had complete lows like
when Russia was seen to have invaded
Georgia okay
shaquiesha Philly was the darling of the
West other people in Russia think
checkers really
just trying to bounce NATO into letting
George are in of course Ukraine's been
very very controversial but again there
are two sides to that story as serious
analysts of the region know so on the
one hand I think people are completely
intrigued by the Russians you know that
here in London there are Russians all
over the place so many of them have done
great things and are doing great things
and a very very impressive people others
who seemed to be quite with all respect
sleazy and where do they get their money
from and so on so I think Russia is
sometimes the other sometimes it's the
enemy but on the other hand people feel
but these are the guys you know if if we
hadn't have had the Soviets in the
second world war we were lost so there's
always been this ambivalence there's
always been this area air of mystique an
intrigue I think as Western people we
see Russians as Europeans so we judge
them by higher standards than we may
judge people from elsewhere in the world
but we also see them as different to us
and I think at the moment it pains me to
say because you know I've spent a lot of
my life in Russia and and think highly
of that particularly the Russian people
I think I wouldn't be truthful if I
didn't say that we are now at the post
Cold War low in terms of relations
between the Western world certainly the
UK and America and Russia maybe you feel
the same way not ending his Cold War too
because you know in the Cold War you
wouldn't be sitting here right I get a
visa and go to Moscow you wouldn't have
hundreds of thousands of Western people
living in Moscow as you do Europe's
biggest city 18 odd million people you
wouldn't have BP owning a fifth of
Rosneft which of course is majority
owned by the Russian state you wouldn't
have Siemens Lieber L'Oreal Volkswagen
all these thoroughbred Western companies
having huge
three presences in Russia you wouldn't
have tons and tons of Russian kids here
at British public schools so culturally
we are completely enmeshed we always
were you know so many leading
intellectuals in the West particularly
in Britain and America are actually
Russian emigre is over the years we've
always been fascinated with Russian
culture no one could say that you know
Shostakovich and Tchaikovsky aren't at
the pinnacle of European cultural
achievement because of course they are
to say nothing of the great poets and
novelists yet of course we are in a
situation where the west and Russia are
in some senses on the opposite sides of
the war in the civil war in Syria
everyone knows who is a takes any
interest at all that Syria is
strategically incredibly important for
the Russians because of the warm water
ports not least it's artists everybody
knows that Putin thinks that we should
keep us ad where he is where the West
having previously thought that now
thinks that we should remove us ad then
again on the other hand the Western
Russia are on the same side when it
comes to ridding the region of ISIL and
there has been cooperation when it comes
to you know strikes to try and keep that
Islamic threat on the backfoot so and
many you know maybe it's not necessarily
an easy thing to say but many serious
analysts of the region in leading
Western think tanks and universities
think well you know we can't really
solve the Russia the Middle East or even
stabilize the Middle East without
talking to the Iranians emerging
regional power broker of course
historically a pretty huge presence in
the region and the Syrians and the only
external force who can do that is is
Moscow and is that do you think the only
reason that given the antagonism that we
now see that the West is prepared to
continue talking to Russia despite what
this perception that Russia is the other
is that the reason we're still talking
to Russia basically now I think I think
that even during the Cold War we were
talking to Russia we obviously talked to
Russia a lot more
now you know Russia's still supplying 40
percent of Europe's Western Europe's gas
you know there's a there's a hard
pipeline now between northern Russia and
Germany and another one being built but
much less true for Britain isn't there
Britain gets a lot less of its gas and
no it does it does but you know gas is a
fungible thing if if if that Russian gas
wasn't there then what would happen to
the gas that's in Norway that currently
comes to the UK you couldn't you can
yeah there is obviously a Western
European dependence on Russian energy
even at the height of the Cold War there
was never any question or never really
any credible threat for the Soviet Union
to not pump that gas the Soviet Union at
the time needed the hard currency
it needs the hard currency less now
contrary to what we often read in the
West Russia fiscally is an incredibly
strong state has very very low sovereign
debt and increasingly is able to exploit
its gas East to China since sanctions
came in one of the big implications of
sanctions as you know Constantine is
that Russia and China have got much
closer
you've got pipelines now existing the
ESPO pipeline the East Siberia
pacificocean pipeline from Russia to
China and again another one being built
so Russia does have options but I don't
think you know when the Russians stay
even though fiscally it's completely
solvent it's still getting about 40 to
45 percent of those state revenues from
oil and gas and a lot of that is from
export so I don't think they're going to
stop that and those energy exports
anytime soon though what's interesting
is that the Russians now as and when
they want to there they sort sidle up to
OPEC they're not members of OPEC but
there's been a kind of Saudi Russian
loving in recent years to try and keep
all prices relatively low in order to
try and spank the US shale producers
because below 50 dollars the US shale
producer it just doesn't work all their
leverage force to pieces interesting now
that the Saudis have got this IPO coming
up they're selling off their huge oil
companies
now to your Emeco they want a higher oil
price and I think one of the
implications of these airstrikes in
Syria not a big oil provider of course
but stoking up concern about the Middle
East is that we could see all prices
going much higher now with the both the
Russians and the Saudis quite happy to
see that happen what's quite interesting
is we've seen with the poisoning of the
former Russian spy and we've also seen
Russian collusion or suspected Russian
collusion in the American election why
do you think Russia is being so
aggressive in those instances at the
moment is it part of a grand strategy or
is it just a warning to the West that
they're still very much a global
superpower I remember sitting around in
various bars in Moscow in the early 90s
and I was offered for sale nuclear
weapons tanks rifles you get on weapons
in Corydon as well seriously the fact
that there's been a attack on British
soil and Him Cathedral town of Salisbury
is very very shocking and I and I think
Theresa May has played our cards pretty
well actually in terms of her response
I think the Foreign Secretary Boris
Johnson has slightly overplayed his hand
he still thinks he's a newspaper
columnist rather than a foreign
secretary well he is yeah we all know we
all know what happens to one's pros
close to the deadline was shocking and
the British government has to do
something and it's been a mighty
impressive so far if the wheels don't
come off it's been a mighty impressive
sort of rallying of diplomatic forces
you know this country still got some
very very smart
diplomats on the other hand while it was
clearly a Russian and originated
substance we still don't really know who
implemented the substance it may still
be a stretch to say this came straight
from the Kremlin so that bit I don't
think anybody can credibly say that is
slam dunk definite is that not a case of
reputation the lien because Russia does
have previous on this with
in encode out that was investigated and
the brief and I'm not saying the Kremlin
didn't do it all I'm saying is that
there are people who would want the
Kremlin to looked as if they've done it
you know we get into incredibly complex
issues here suffice to say for now that
clearly this hasn't done the rest
relationship with Russia any good at all
and clearly ahead of the World Cup it
wasn't something that is going to endear
people to going to Russia which is it
which is a sort of citizen of the world
is a bit of a shame I was thinking that
getting lots of people from Western
Europe and the rest of the world says
sort of you know get through that iron
curtain of the mind and actually go to
this country where you know it's not
it's not as it's not like it's cracked
up to be in many ways it's the
countryside is very beautiful there are
astonishing people the weather is
actually really good in May and June
worst ever sunstroke in and I think that
could have changed quite a lot of
people's perceptions about Russian yeah
they'd go to Russia and they'd sort of
have a good time because the Russians
know how to throw a party and they
generally do a pretty good job of
organizing international events but this
has clearly put all that back and it'd
be very interesting to see in the weeks
and months after we record this podcast
the extent to which that diplomatic
coalition can hold together as and when
more and more evidence emerges as it
always does about what actually happened
but what do you think about the word
their infiltration as has been suspected
on the American democratic process do
you think that there was really Russian
collusion and if so to what degree well
anybody that cracks open a history book
it's not conspiracy theory to say that
big countries try and influence each
other's election screen I mean come on
it's completely clear that that happens
it's completely clear that America tries
to influence elections Britain tries to
influence Alec
Asians Russia tries to influence
elections anyone that doesn't understand
that isn't isn't watching very closely
it's different to say that this was a
particularly concerted attempt in order
to try and get Trump elected at the
expense of Hillary Clinton I mean I
happen to think I'm no great Trump
supporter but I think the reason Hillary
Clinton get elected was Hillary Clinton
and if you read you know her book what
happened it's not an autobiography as an
alibi ography she blames everyone but
herself I don't think there's been
credible evidence that there was there
was any particularly concerted attempt
by the Russians to influence this
election any more than they tried to
influence any election any time but of
course in the current climate there's a
very willing audience for that view
particularly among people who detest
Trump and I understand why lots of
people detest Trump he's his rhetoric
and the way he conducts himself is
sometimes pretty shocking we'll have to
wait and see what happens what is clear
is that Facebook is and the tech giant's
in general now you know we've gone from
sort of leaning in so piss off they
these t-shirt
Titans were seen as if they could do no
wrong you know do no evil I think was
you can see why they needed it yeah but
but now that you know people the scales
are falling from people's eyes and it's
not just you know my kids constantly on
social media me as a journalist their
mum as a journalist we kind of know that
our data gets pimped and you you you
know you mentioned something on Facebook
and slowly there's an advert to buy it
appearing on your Twitter feed and it's
a little bit wool but the idea that your
data is then you know chopped up and
sold and sold and sold and sold again I
think it's starting to alarm people and
these tech giants they don't pay much
tax they're completely opaque when they
pretend to be transparent they have
absolutely enormous
market power I think Amazon now sells
70% of all books sold in America and 50%
of all retail in America
Google's 80% of risk of search traffic I
mean this reminds me guys have again
history I recently made a documentary
about America in the late eighteen
nineteenth-century the 1890s or the
1900s when eventually Franklin Delano
Roosevelt a Republican unlike you know
FDR in the 30s he was forced by
journalists actually to smash up the
trust to smash up you know the big oil
companies the big sugar trusts the
copper trusts and actually inject some
competition because consumers were
getting absolutely shafted and I wonder
if we aren't going to face a sort of
similar trust busting moment of the tech
giants in in in the US and this whole
sense that you know Facebook whoever's
got the most money can pay Facebook to
micro-target particular voters in
particular constituencies to win
elections and then the whole thing that
were Facebook taking Russian money and
have they been completely straight with
the security services in the US and the
UK it's all feeding into this idea that
you know that these guys aren't you know
the kind of goofy or you know mood a few
billion illusion program yeah but you've
also destroyed our system of government
and you don't pay any tax can you not
lean in can you just pay some tax yeah
so I think people are losing their
patience and the whole Russia narrative
that maybe that they've been
facilitating enhance sort of Russian
involvement in Western elections
particularly when those elections are
leading to people taking office that the
sort of liberal intelligentsia don't
like that's really gaining momentum now
[Music]
[Applause]
can I just say you're the first Russian
I've ever met who can't actually make
tea discuss what's known in the trade
right as gnats piss this is the best
builder podcast we honest with you
that's the only reason we've got you
polonium team truepani imitates better
right so but you mentioned the the
liberal elite you mentioned the tech
giants right one of the interesting
things for me is that one of the big
criticisms that is now being made of
YouTube and and Facebook is that there
is a liberal bias on all these platforms
so for example there are people who make
who have run channels on YouTube like
dave rubin we talked about him before
he's finding increasingly the when he
interviews conservatives or libertarians
even those videos are being demonetised
by youtube and they're not being pushed
and he's losing people are being
randomly unsubscribed from his channel
and things like that are happening so a
lot of the conservative voices in these
supposedly public squares which actually
controlled by the t-shirt wearing
silence tightness that you mentioned
they're now saying that actually it's
not a public square and is being heavily
restricted what do you make of the
implications of the of these shisha
wearing giants from freedom of speech
and for the ability to continue how to
have genuine conversations about
politics like these ones well i've
knocked around in the british media most
of my adult life and you know it's clear
the kind of people who become
journalists tend to be more liberal i
want to change the world kind of people
and and you know the people they didn't
like at university tend to go off and
work for Goldman Sachs or become lawyers
so there's a kind of natural artistic
lefty bias to journalism and I'm a sort
of amalgam of things I'm
Scalise conservative but socially I
guess liberal so I do react like America
yeah I do i do recognize i do recognize
a lot of that but if if the sort t-shirt
it tightens the t-shirts at toe rags i
think we should rechristen them if they
think they can use their enormous power
to you know piss off the GOP piss off
the British Conservative Party they need
to I think it's as a Democrat as in a
small D Democrats in democracy not a
member of the Democrat Party in the US
and as somebody who believes in
democracy I think actually it's quite
important even though I like small
government that the government's in
these big powerful countries now assert
themselves and tell these guys yeah
you're very clever and you've done very
well and you give lots of money to
charity but you're not the government
we're the government and we are elected
and that is our mandate and so we're
actually gonna now and not for the sake
of it but because you do need to be
reined in we're gonna rein you in so
they understand that in a democracy
where there's ever flow between left and
right you really don't want to upset
unduly go out of your way to upset
politicize of the political spectrum
because in a fair fight they're gonna
win you know quite a lot of the time I'm
not saying that you pander to the right
in any way but you know conservatives
are quite often in office in the US and
the UK and across Western Europe
increasingly so actually and I think it
would then just be make smart business
sense to not just be even not just see
to be even-handed if you're if you're
controlling the kind of you know the
valves and the diodes of our thought
processes because basically he got a big
switch that controls the internet you
would then actually have to be
even-handed because it would not make
business sense to not be even-handed I
mean for instance look we got the BBC
here in the UK and I'm not the greatest
fan of the BBC but I massively admire it
and make lot of British people feel that
way right because it does make
incredible programs
nature programs and documentaries really
astonishing a world-class sets the
standard for the world but I think the
news is really stodgy I think there are
far too many sort of posh white people
on the news there aren't enough
working-class people involved with the
news there's not enough diversity of any
kind gender race and class but having
said that even the BBC which is
institutionally kind of left liberal
Guardian reading and I say that you know
I'm talking about many of my closest
friends this is confusing even the BBC
you know it won't take the piss right
most people at the BBC don't like the
Tories but when it comes to an election
they won't take the piss they'll be
even-handed when it came to the brexit
referendum they and I speak as a brexit
ear they were not impeccably but for the
most part they did really well during
the referendum well usse interesting to
me because you you and that makes sense
well you say the BBC is inherently lefty
I know lots of lefties you say it's
incredibly right-wing no but that's
because you know lots of sort of Corbyn
Easter not media the people the reason
people are ultra left-wing is because
they don't earn enough to pay tax or
more or because they've got you know an
old man with the trust fund and yet in
stein and they can pretend that they
don't care about money yeah exactly yeah
let's name them name and shame naming
shame they go to their poor shops where
they pay money in order to look like
they don't have money you know is that
as well
sounding old now okay but just because
we are yes way but just to go back to
the tech chance I think there is a
unification between left and right where
we're all getting a little bit pissed
off that and these people aren't paying
tax Oh big big-time big-time and it's
not just they're not paying tax so that
is a big part of it it's also that then
monopoly power is just taking out a lot
of retail very a
and smaller businesses and also you know
so I I'm an author I write books yeah it
is not fair that these bastards just
basically scan my book and put it on the
internet and don't take it down you
don't so many books these days unless
it's a really sort of salacious current
affairs book because everybody knows
within three weeks they can download a
PDF so if you read there's a wonderful
book that I'd recommend to you guys into
all all all viewers
it's called move fast and break things
by Jonathan Taplin I wrote a review
about it recently on a website called
unheard unhcr Diaz is not part of the
hood
I know unheard unheard calm where I
write a sort of alternative weekly
column not my Telegraph column more of a
kind of saw a laying back column role
and are sitting at my desk column and I
wrote a review of this book and it
really is an amazing book so Jonathan
Chaplin was a music producer you work
with some of the greats including Bob
Dylan and he wrote a book and it was
over a year ago now a long time before
all this tech giant stuff
there's discontent blew up predicting
the lot because these guys have just
taken away the living of so many artists
and musicians and authors and it cannot
be right that you can spend a huge
amount of time producing content you
know we're all content providers we're
writers we're comedians whatever we are
all we have is our creativity and
pathetic I know but this is what we do
it's not fair if somebody can just
reproduce it and distribute it and get
advertising around the distribution of
your creative output and not pay you and
that's basically what's happening and
this is another way that society is
going to get really upset with these
guys because when the creative people
start getting upset and they're starting
to get upset now the and Jonathan
Chaplin really puts his finger on that
move faster break things was zuker bergs
phrase in the early days of facebook if
we're not moving fast and breaking
things we're not moving fast enough you
know a really lor double idea you'd be
disruptive innovate create fantastic
now they really are breaking things
they're breaking the ability of artistic
people to make money from their music
and from their from their writing and so
we end up with you know there's so much
less choice in music the internet hasn't
given us choice than when I was a kid
it's so hard to be an alternative artist
now an alternative musician because
there's just a few little songs that get
picked by somebody in a room somewhere
and they're the ones that get hammered
on Facebook and Google and go everywhere
and go viral and nothing else gets a
look and then nothing else can make a
living because because it's just
reproduced on the Internet and and the
tech giant's don't do anything to take
down stuff when copyright is clearly
being broken left right and center
[Music]
[Applause]
well let's talk about your book clean
brexit tell us a little bit about what
made you write it and what was the
message you wanted to send to the world
it's you know quite a lot of those
columns I write I saw people often call
them sort of fire-breathing and and very
polemical and all the rest of it but I
have got the inside me there's a sort of
inner nerd and this was my inner nerd
coming to the fore so I was I was very
much against the UK joining the single
currency there was a big debates about
that in the late 90s in the early 2000s
and I wrote a lot at the time I think
the single currency were very claps I
don't think will work and of course a
lot of my very liberal write on friends
said oh you horrible person why don't
you want to join the single currency you
must be a Nazi yeah absolutely no no I
would compile I know I would retort I've
just read a lot about the history of
currency unions and the fact that they
always split up unless there's sort of
lots and lots of political Union which
it was never going to happen in Europe
so I was always a sort of EMU sceptic
person not that I didn't like birds
Amyas European monetary union I was
always skeptical of the projects of
European monetary union and I always
felt and I wrote this back in the late
nineties many times that it would lead
to you know the the European Union which
I broadly supported the idea of free
trade with more broadly free trade and
doing stuff together
I thought single currency would make it
incoherent but I was always a supporter
of Britain on balance staying within the
EU but then you had the Treaty of Lisbon
you had the Treaty of nice these
incredibly centralizing treaties and you
had countries voting against them and
basically being ignored by Brussels and
told to vote again and people the the EU
I think in the last ten years started to
become anti-democratic not just
undemocratic but anti-democratic and I
started to get increasingly upset that
Britain was trying to negotiate a new
model of doing things looser more
democratic
collaborating and cooperating without
trying to subsume more and more power
away from local politicians here in the
UK and the the tipping point for me was
when David Cameron tried to renegotiate
with the European Union you'll remember
it back in early 2016 and they just
basically said you know piss off change
it change it in any way and Cameron knew
I think then that he had a fight on his
hands if he was gonna win this
referendum so it was at that point that
I decided I would actually argue for
Britain to leave the European Union and
I did a huge amount of work researching
it researching the trade deals that the
European Union had done the trade deals
that it hadn't done the trade deals that
Britain was likely to be able to do
outside of the European Union and I
decided in the end as the referendum
approached there was so much nonsense
being spoken on the mainstream media I
don't think people well most people
weren't deliberately lying but lots of
things were being said that were just
factually wrong about our relationship
with the rest of the world about our
relationship with Europe that I got
together with another economist and we
wrote a sort of fast-paced and
accessible but really quite detailed
book with lots of footnotes about the
history of the European Union and about
the best way as we saw it to negotiate
our exit
so you think bricks it will broadly be a
positive thing for this country will be
broadly a positive I'm afraid I do
strike strike me down I do I think it I
think the single mark our membership of
what we call the single market is the
benefits are massively overstated
there's no single market in services and
we're of course the service superpower I
think the benefits of being inside the
customs union are massively overstated
being in the customs union means that
our consumers pay far far more for all
imports from outside the European Union
it means we can't cut trade deals with
the rest of the world outside the
European Union I mean I remember when we
joined what was called the European
Economic Community I was about five
years old
back then it was 40% of the world yeah
even though I only had you know nine
countries when we joined now it's when
we leave it will be 15% of the world
economy even though it will have 27
countries so the growth is beyond Europe
now the popular world population is
beyond Europe the UK is a European
country obviously but it really has a
lot of very very interesting cultural
and practical and logistical connections
with the rest of the world and I think
it's going to be much better for our
kids and our grandkids if we spend a lot
more of our time effort diplomatic and
commercial energy connecting to and
trading with the rest of the world
rather than the European Union we will
always trade with the European Union but
the sense has been created that if we're
not in the European Union we won't trade
with the European Union really America
does over 300 billion dollars of trade a
year with the European Union from
outside the European Union China does
huge amounts of trade with the European
Union as Japan from outside the European
Union so I felt there were real scare
tactics going on some of the stuff
coming out the British Treasury and the
Bank of England and other sort of
international organizations like the
OECD sort of push Western think-tank in
France I mean I knew as an economist
what they were saying was utter utter
nonsense and deliberately designed to
try and frighten the British people into
voting to stay inside the European Union
but the European Union is basically a
protectionist club big companies like it
that's why they pour so much money into
publicity to support it small companies
where the real growth and energy is in
this country tend not to like the
European Union and then the British
people in their wisdom even though they
were called thick and stupid and racist
and xenophobic they voted the way they
voted and I happen to think that was an
astonishing outcome it is difficult to
go through the process of brexit all the
complaints an hour about the process of
BRICS
the EU or Brussels in particular a bunch
of unelected you know not particularly
clever people very unimpressive a lot of
these sort of life civil servants in
Brussels they're making it as difficult
as they possibly can a lot of the media
in the UK doesn't want it to happen so
as making it sound as difficult as it
possibly can and yet still despite sort
of ultra Mainers trying to reverse the
biggest act of democracy in British
history the polls show that you know a
majority of people still want to leave I
think it will be absolutely fine I think
it will be absolutely fine and I think
there will be other my hope is not that
the European Union suffers in any way my
hope is that a very big economy like the
UK leaving and making a successor of
being outside the European Union while
still trading with the European Union
doesn't lead to the European Union
getting weaker but it convinces people
that the European Union should be looser
and more democratic and less kind of D
resist and always pushing for the super
state status but now that's interesting
that you're talking about scare stories
because I've been reading you know you
read the pie read the papers a lot and
you always hear in the papers you know
whether it's from The Times The
Telegraph or from The Guardian you know
that these banks are going to be leaving
we are famously that's where we generate
a lot of our tax income from can you see
these big banks leaving the City of
London bleed nonces lloyd blank find the
CEO of goldman sachs he sort of texting
tweeting all you know be spending less
time in london why the [ __ ] are you
building your european headquarters in
Farringdon may come out in the last
couple of days it's got almost no
publicity so yeah of course your bloody
stay in London because it's the
financial capital of the world certainly
it's one of the top two financial
capital of the world completely
irrefutable London isn't beating with
Frankfurt or Paris Frankfurt is barely
in the top 20 financial ket cities in
the world Paris is barely in the top 30
London's competing with Singapore and
New York yeah
and the idea
that the world's major banks won't want
to be in London is complete nonsense
London is even the banking capital of
the eurozone right and if you listen to
you know people like Wolfgang Schauble
who's the former german finance minister
incredibly financially literate bloke a
finance minister actually knows about
finance thing yeah he was saying at the
time barely reported look we really
don't want to cut off from London
because most German companies big German
companies when they want to raise money
and so poles they do in London so it was
always nonsense and I'm afraid that was
what kind of pissed me off enough to
write the book because I kept listening
to the television and I kept hearing on
the radio stuff that was being spurted
out from all the big corporate bodies in
the UK the CBI and and so on saying that
all this woe was gonna happen and I just
knew the common sense was there it was
nonsense I was gonna say so what do you
think about the brexit campaign because
now there was a I don't know if you saw
as an article in The Observer yesterday
that that you know some of the funds
weren't being used or you know there was
a slight misappropriation of funds and
all the rest of it you know there was a
350 million for the NHS which turns out
somewhat of a lie the fact really we
left yet well okay okay fair enough but
but this is my point right well we leave
it's a fact that we won't pay 10 billion
pounds a year so they you and okay so
what do want to do with that 10 billion
in fact it will be it would have been
more now because the bills going up so
we can spend that money on the NHS if we
want to it's not a lie we haven't left
well this is we're still paying every
year and we will still pay every year
during the transition period as some you
know I was the guy who back in 2016
wrote the pamphlet that said we need a
transition period because the EU funding
framework is a seven-year thing that
goes all the way to 2020 so in order to
make the negotiation work
let's keep paying to 2020 and call it a
transition period to keep everybody calm
that's ultimately what happened we were
always going to keep paying
until the transition period and when we
stop paying then we'll have money that
we're not paying to Europe because we've
been the second biggest net contributor
to the EU since we entered and then we
can spend that money on other things
well this is an interesting point for me
as an immigrant in this country one of
the things that we've discussed with
several guests already is this idea that
during the campaign the allegation was
made then you referred to that anyone
who votes for brexit or most people who
vote for brexit do so because they're
racist a xenophobic how much of the
conversation has become what you just
picked up on which is slogan i's de
sensually it's a fact free conversation
and we're just talking about what your
age there was there have been sort of
fact-free elements on both sides and i
think maybe there's been some financial
impropriety on both sides i wasn't
involved in there i mean i could have
been involved leave so if i wanted to
but i didn't i wanted to be an
independent person just saying what i
thought i think it did become quite fact
free there was slogan izing but some of
us in the media and our columns and our
broadcasts were trying to be a bit more
high-fiber and I've often found myself
during the referendum people literally
stopping me in the street and emailing
me are hundreds of emails from people oh
can you just explain that to me I've
been doing my research and yeah
ordinary punters did a huge amount of
work to try and understand what was
going on and I think a lot of the
British media did lapse into just Punch
and Judy debates but I think there were
some people on both sides and people on
neither side who were trying to to give
the facts I was disappointed though in
the in the British government in
Cameron's government you know it has to
be recorded because it's true and it's
outrageous that the British government
two days before we have this thing
called perda where the government is
allowed isn't allowed to spend any more
government money on a referendum or or
election and two days before that the
British government used taxpayers money
nine million pounds to distribute a
completely overwhelmingly Pro
remain information leaflet and that 9
million didn't then count so the state
money which the remains side got which
was meant to be even with the leaf side
so that was really really best it was it
was sly it was it was deeply unfair but
did you have people calling you racist
or xenophobia time what was that like
very very very distressing I am I am you
know I'm somebody who grew up with the
name like Liam Halligan when Britain and
Ireland were basically at war and you
know and back then the UK was a lot less
tolerant than it is now you know my
family yeah my father's still around
grew up in the West of Ireland speaking
Gaelic you know he he in his heart he's
very grateful to the UK he was able to
come here and make a living that he
couldn't have made in rural Ireland back
in the day so I'm not complaining but it
isn't nice when you are absolutely of
immigrant stock yourself and you've
tried to you know make your way in a
society and bring other people up behind
you and grew up in an incredibly
multicultural community as I did in in
in Northwest London it's horrible I mean
it's just a character assassinations and
it's just a smear and from people who
don't know you personally they've never
seen you and the people who tend to
accuse other people have racist racism
in this country tends to be people who
grew up in ass of all white environment
and didn't meet a sort of black person
until they went to Oxford you know it's
really it's outrageous to call someone
like me that with the background that I
have but you know that's that's the way
it is when people have sense that you
know more than they do and you've done
your research they'll try characters
that's not you to discredit you I think
part of the problem with the Brixton
movement for instance my father who is
he married immigrant my mother's Latin
American and he's very much Pro brexit
and he will sit down with people and
explain why I think what didn't help
with brakes is a fact you have people
like Katie Hopkins coming out in support
of it and immediately you have a person
like that well you know Faraj
I'm flaunting it and immediately that
tarnishes what is potentially great I
agree and you know without you keep
winning 13% of the vote as they did in
the 2015 election without you keep
having won the European elections in
2014 there wouldn't have been a
referendum Cameron gave her a referendum
because he knew that you keep we're
going to just wipe out a lot of a lot of
but they were gonna remake the electoral
map
I mean you Kipp they didn't but they got
one seat in the 2015 general election
but they came second in about 160 seats
no no they got something like 3 million
by absolutely absolutely astonishing
they got 13 percent of the vote in the
2015 general election so yes ours
brightly yeah has his footnote in
history rightly and you got give the guy
credit for that on the other hand some
things he says I really don't approve of
you know standing in front of a poster
full of people you know with dark
complexions breaking-point my stomach
turned that was a complete mistake I
think a lot of what leave EU did as
opposed to vote leave so vote leave was
the official campaign leave EU was fair
our guys who were a lot more hardline I
think levy you you know did they
subtract votes I think fare ours being
around a lot subtracted votes
I think if Faraj had gone on holiday
three months before the referendum then
you'd have got a bigger majority in
favor of brexit because Paulus didn't
convince anybody who was in two minds no
moderate is going to look at fair hours
I think all I agree with you as always
the guy put up in the debates or nearly
always as the kind of pro brexit voice
which I thought was wrong there are many
many moderate people who were Pro brexit
you know and I think Giesler Stewart who
viewers may not know she really came to
the fore so this is a German woman right
for the Labor Party with a massive
record on human rights who negotiated
the UK's side during the EU Constitution
totally signed up your a file and she
was breaks it because she thought the EU
become overbearing and when she was on
the the public debates and on the
television representing the the brexit
side you know the polls went wild
because you had a lot of middle aged
people moderate people particularly
moderate moderate women saying she's
amazing yeah whereas if it's always
Farage's brexit people are thinking well
I can see all these reasons for a brexit
and I've done my reading and all that
that but I just think Farraj is turning
me off so I'm gonna stick with remain so
I actually think Pharaohs was a net
subtract I completely I know the guy you
know congratulate him for getting the
referendum absolutely and I congratulate
him for saying what he believes and
campaigning he's not a racist you know
these aren't guys aren't the BNP they
don't want to deport people on you know
that there are many sort of reasonable
people in UK people I know quite well
I'm not a you keep supporter because I
think they go a little bit too far in
many in many areas and I don't think
they're kind of global enough in their
outlook but I think during the
referendum if ours had gone on holiday
then the the majority in favor of brexit
would have been more like 6040 no I
completely agree with you because I
really hate this you know mantra that
brexit equals racism it's stupid and
it's wrong and it's Bureau and it's
pathetic and if it actually been more
people like yourself coming out and go
look this is why I vote breaks it ABCDE
and F I'd be like okay I'll go away and
I'll have a think about it the fact you
just get someone like Katie Hopkins
wheeled out and the moment she could
argue that white is you know it is you
know white is white and I'd still be
like I'm not sure if ye Braley is white
Katie considering we need a final
solution on Muslims you see what I mean
but Matt well he needs just a full
disclosure both Francis and I voted to
remain but actually for both certainly
for me I don't want to speak for Francie
it was a quite a wake-up moment actually
yeah both bricks are and Trump with this
realization that maybe the liberal
bubble that I'd been living in didn't
have everything right but actually I'm
it doesn't mean though that all people
have voted breaks it support Trump which
is another ID which is another you know
little segue that is I mean let's since
we've had this referendum there has been
a constant drumbeat of negativity there
are people in this country who are
determined to reverse this referendum a
lot of them are sitting at taxpayers
expense unelected in that erm and clad
chamber of of remain which is the House
of Lords and nothing could be more
damaging for British democracy you had
an astonishing almost sort of democratic
uprising from regions of the UK where
unexpectedly they voted for brexit and
if we try and sort of lawyer our way out
of that and and and stitch up the
results so people don't get to leave the
European Union and that means leaving
the single market and that means leaving
the customs union these are the two main
legal structures of the European Union
then I'm not gonna sit here and I
wouldn't go on television or write in my
newspaper columns that there's going to
be civil unrest you won't be surprised
would you I know I'm not gonna say I'm
not gonna predict that but what I am
gonna say is that you will get millions
of British people who will never vote
again and will always be upset that
their vote has been erased you know
people who shop at little yeah their
vote is just as important as people who
shop at Waitrose people who are plumbers
and roofers yeah are just as important
as people you know who got a nice degree
from a sort of mid-ranking university
and work at a law firm it's one person
one vote it's called democracy we don't
like it go to North Korea I was gonna
insult you by saying go to Russia
Venezuela where my mum's from Liam and I
have a long-running thing about Russia
but yeah I feel about Britain actually
much like you feel about Russia it's a
country that's that I've I've been
proven
to live in I feel very grateful for and
I'm sure you go back to you go back to
Russia and you hear a lot of negativity
about Britain and you say well okay
that's true but actually yeah and I'm
similar with Russia because I know
Russia you know personally a lot more
than most British people do just as you
clearly know Britain's you're incredibly
well now having lived here for so long
and being so culturally immersed than
most people living in Russia and you
know you probably you know when you go
home you know if you if you if you mix
in in certain circles what you say about
the UK could be quite unpopular but you
know it's true right and so you have to
say it I mean you could win power not
say it and to a much lesser degree but
there's some similarity with me when I
hear things like you know I spend a lot
of my life sort of over the years
studying the Russian economy that was
what I really specialized in and when I
hear things like oh it's all loyal and
gas I just have to say well it isn't
actually 18% of GDP is oil and gas yeah
the service sector is twice as big as
the oil and gas sector because if you
don't say that then I mean what's the
point
well in just to finish up on break say
what I wanted to say first of all as an
immigrant here one of the things that
really pissed me off about the brexit
campaign was this idea the British
people erases xenophobes and even though
I voted remain that there was nothing
that annoyed me more than that because
I've lived in this country for a very
long time and Britain is one of the most
tolerant countries you're a Russian he's
Venezuelan and I'm a plastic paddy and
we're sitting here doing our stuff and
saying what we born right um we've made
a decent living our families of made
decent livings and and we love Britain
right yeah absolutely so here's the
question you really doesn't always love
us but you made a very solid case for
why economically brexit that's a good
thing but is not the legacy of Brecht
said this social lack of cohesion and
the social conflict that we now find
ourselves in where people are after the
referendum going if you voted for breaks
that unfriend me never speaking to you
again literally families being
two one apart by the vote things like
that is that not all depends it's all in
our hands constants in it depends how we
handle it I mean do we grow up and
realize that people can you know it's
completely reasonable to have in a close
election to come down on different sides
will we use the newfound freedoms that
we have things we can't really do
effectively inside the European Union
like set our taxation the way we want to
like do regional policy the way we want
to have policy towards our farms our
fishing communities our energy markets
there's lots of ways that the EU has
constrained this country's domestic
policymaking if we respond to these new
freedoms in a way that's inclusive in a
way that rebalances the UK economy away
from just London and the south east
towards the regions more I mean a lot of
my book with Jared lines clean brexit is
about what we can do once we've left the
whole of the back half of it actually
and a big thing that we emphasize is
regional policy outside the European
Union and I certainly hope that we do
really rebalance this country we have a
tremendous opportunity to build not just
sort of try and empower alternative
growth sensors apart from London and the
southeast
let's link up those northern cities
those great cities known around the
world for creativity ingenuity
you know Liverpool cultural capital of
popular music Manchester yeah one of the
main sources of the Industrial
Revolution these are incredible places
and people want to invest there people
want to be associated with them they've
got fantastic universities they've got a
lot of human capital they've been on
their uppers kind of in the last
generation or two but you know let's
let's build international airports there
let's bring in investment from around
the world
let's project those cities around the
world and let's try and encourage more
of our young people to live in those
cities rather than thinking that you
have to come to London's make a success
of yourself now you don't Germany's not
like that it's not like you have to go
to Berlin to making success for yourself
all those Frankfurt there's Munich there
are regional powerhouses the UK needs to
become a much more regional country not
all about London and South East isn't it
fantastic to have London you know one of
the world cities in our country isn't it
great but I think too much we've over
emphasized London at the expense of
these other countries these other parts
of the country and outside the European
Union I think we've got a major chance
to put that right Liam but you're
talking in a very cerebral level you're
obviously very knowledgeable very
intelligent guy and we're very grateful
to have you here but the only but
actually is nothing to do with you is
that these conversations are not being
had at that cerebral level they're being
had on a kind of Facebook you're racist
you're xenophobia this your that don't
ever speak to me again kind of level and
because is because a lot of people are
still hoping that this thing can be
reversed and you know because people
racist enough we can discredit this
process enough then people are gonna
want to reverse it if we can spread
enough scare stories about how the
economy's gonna collapse and this is
cliff edge and you know goldman sachs
are gonna leave and deutsche bank are
gonna leave then maybe people will be
scared and we can have another
referendum you know Vince Cable wants
another referendum because he didn't
agree with the person yeah this is a guy
who told his own party conference in
September 2016 after the referendum that
I really don't think we can insult the
electorate by having another referendum
and that was on the record it was
recorded and yet suddenly he changes his
mind and think so of course we need
another referendum because he's trying
to read and remake his party and the Lib
Dem since they've said that they've got
nowhere in the polls I mean this is a
great party I'm a real soft spot for the
Lib Dems we need the Lib Dems in British
politics but they went to the electorate
in 2017 with this we're gonna reverse
brexit and they got the lowest result in
their history the SNP went to the the
lecturer in Scotland with we're going to
reverse brick
and they and they lost a third of their
seats you know I mean come on this these
cloying elites thinking that they can
reverse brexit because it kind of
undermines their sensibilities they've
got to understand that people they don't
who voted against them are just as
important as they are when it comes to
the ballot box that's what democracy is
about and we they have to get on with it
and we have to make the best of it
people who voted leave and have a vision
of how good it could be and people were
voted remain and who are perhaps a
little bit more you need to be a bit a
little bit less enthusiastic but the
real key to this whole thing is that
there is a big chunk of people who voted
remain yeah in good faith many of whom I
love literally members of my closest
family and they realize okay it's not
think oh the way I wanted to go but what
would it be like if every time we have
some sort of democratic situation we
contest the result for years and years
in the future well this is it what we
have is chaos which is essentially what
is happening now I mean we if you think
about it I've never voted conservative I
vote Labour but I would never dream once
to reach omegle in of demanding a
recount
I just wouldn't because like not unless
there was absolute transgression yeah we
have had electoral fraud in this company
I mean there was a famous case in in
Blackburn a few years ago if there's
electoral fraud of course it's got to be
rooted out but of but of course an
election is different to a referendum in
that an election is part of a natural
cycle and Alastair Campbell often says
oh you know when you lose the election
you don't stop campaigning no Alastair
because that's an election yeah and this
is a referendum and Parliament voted by
6 to 1 for the bill to hold a referendum
in early 2016 to give this vote to the
British people and to now try and
reverse that and that the point about
brexit is that then once we've
breakfasted Parliament becomes a lot
more powerful because all these laws
come back to Parliament so you have
people in Parliament saying when you
said you know we wanted
you want its Parliament to be powerful
yeah I do after brexit Parliament we'll
have a lot more power you are now trial
immense rights to do something it's a
reverse breaks it that makes it less
powerful well there's only one
counter-argument that's not answered by
that which is would leave and not be
doing the same thing right now if you'd
lost well you'd have to you'd have to
build up I mean leave leave waited 40
years and we joined we joined the EU you
probably don't know this we joined the
European community without a referendum
we went in in 73 by dicta that was Ted
Heath Josh will be out now campaigning
terrible it was only two years after it
was only two years after that we
actually had a referendum in 1975 well
my point is you don't acknowledge your
Faraj would be out on the streets now
campaigning for a second referendum if
he'd lost I don't think I don't think
the body politic would have given him a
second referendum
I mean look look what's happening in a
lot of the remain as he wanted secondly
ultra Romanians who want a second
referendum they're not calling for a
second referendum on Scottish
independence are they because broadly
they're people who want to keep the EU
the UK together you have to be grown-up
about this you're gonna get into some
kind of Banana Republic type situation
where it just becomes tribal or a Quebec
style situation where there's a
never-ending look Britain trades on its
legal stability right our comparative
advantage in the world is if you come to
our courts right it doesn't matter who
you are you're gonna get a fair hearing
right the British government isn't gonna
be able to rig the courts yeah that is
what we have we've built that up over
centuries of not always doing the right
there is a sense now and it's not a
hundred percent guaranteed but you're
gonna get a fair hearing we sell our
debt to the rest of the world we need a
stable currency if Britain becomes so
unstable that we're sort of we voted to
leave the European Union and then before
we vote leave the European Union we vote
to stay in the European Union and then
what the EU gonna do they're gonna let
us come back in but not be in the euro
they're gonna let us have the rebate
that we need
all those years ago it's gotta be
absolute carnage and you know what our
exports our trade with the European
Union is about 10% of GDP right about
10% of GDP let's let's let's say
worst-case scenario worst-case scenario
that our trade with the EU like
collapses by 10% yeah that's like 1%
over GDP over many years
it's the this is rounding error stuff
now of course whether in the EU or not
is important to our identity but I would
say actually while British people tend
to love continental Europe we also
almost uniquely in Europe have
astonishing connections with the rest of
the world you think about something very
close to my heart
because a lot of the families I grew up
with were Indian families right and
families had come over from the
Caribbean my best friends in the world
those people I grew up with yet the
connections we have with the Indian
subcontinent the connections we have
with Australasia the incredible
connection we have with the United
States no one else has these connections
the English language the fact that there
are all these mad Brits all working all
over the world running companies and
building companies we aren't a normal
European country we have I wouldn't say
bigger broader horizons we have more
global horizons than a lot of those
countries and I think a lot of British
people whether they were highly educated
or not often even when they weren't
sense that sense that the growth is
outside of Europe now Europe's been the
slowest growing continent in the world
apart from Antarctica the last 20 years
and I think a lot of people's sense is
that it's yes we'll keep trading with
Europe but not at the expense of trading
more with the rest of the world listen
we're running out of time I think that's
a perfect perfect well well thank you
for having me it's been absolute
pleasure Liam tell us your Twitter at
Liam Halligan but not that complicated
and
as well your book is called clean bricks
it's cool clean brexit my podcast is
called lend me your ear
one of what kind of stuff do you talk
about the part I tend to I tend to talk
to I tend to have a sort of detailed
policy discussions so briefs people I've
recently spoke to I spoke to David Davis
the brexit secretary I spoke to an
incredible economist Nobel winning
economist called Amartya Sen I spoke to
Richard Thaler who's the guy that
invented behavioral economics he's the
current Nobel laureate I just spoke to
this incredible guy on my podcast called
Peter Platzer who has created he's got a
huge network of satellites in space and
he sells the data that they collect on
things like the weather and ship
movements to commercial companies really
incredible guy amazing
lend me you here let me Liam Halligan at
Liam Halligan I'm Constance and kitchen
ad Constance and Kissin and I'm Francis
foster up failing human and if you by
the way if you've enjoyed this great
episode please please please follow us
on instagram and at twitter at trigger
pod and also please if you've enjoyed it
leave us a rating five stars please and
also leave a nice comment underneath and
also subscribe and tell a friend but
thank you so much for tuning in and we
hope to see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you